[Music]  [Applause]  i say either  yeah either i say neither and i say  neither  either neither neither let's  call the whole thing off  [Applause]  catch up excuse me  yummy  good evening eddie hey mrs chen good  evening venom  mrs chen  [Music]  you and i are the same  every decision we ever make  [Music]  who do we leave behind  and how do we leave them  waiting in the darkness with the rescuer  who never comes  welcome back eddie brock it's been a  long time  miss you so much  [Applause]  soon come chaos  chaos soon  the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived  yet no we had a deal  what's gonna happen you're gonna stop  protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen  no no you cannot eat mrs chen what  [Music]  nothing